we are in the topic of algebra at the
moment and so we're going to be learning
something a particular law a particular
shortcut to do with working with algebra
but as you recall everything in algebra
like s's and P's and Q's
they just stand for numbers right that's
why we call them pronumerals remember
that so everything that we know about
numbers applies to algebra so I'm gonna
start by considering something really
simple to do with numbers but then we're
going to see how it applies to algebra
okay so if I asked you to write down
what is four times I'm gonna give you
let's go with 57 okay now with some time
even without a calculator
I reckon you could pretty quickly give
me the answer but that's actually not
what I'm interested in I want to think
about what it means okay Merak okay yes
so what what Marik is doing is he's
breaking is 57 into two pieces right so
what he's really doing is saying there's
a 50 here that's what the five stands
for and then okay so sorry that 57 is
really short-haired 457 isn't it right
fifty plus seven so I can say that's
what will you say marry four times 50
and yep I'm gonna write that in the
order that I had it before cool now just
pause there at this point I think we
could probably all do this even without
a calculator right say it all with me 4
times 50 years 300 and then 4 times 7 is
28 very good
so you're like okay great I have an
answer now even if I'd not really hand
you with my 57 times tables okay thumbs
up now what we've done here this
strategy of breaking apart 57 into 50
plus 7 right we didn't need to do it
with numbers we could have just reached
for our calculator but other times when
we're dealing with algebra we kind of do
need to think of it as two separate
things so now I want you to further
considering this let's consider if I
don't have 4 times 57 but if I for some
4 times something like a plus 7 okay now
for this guy here to carry
I know you know the answer that's right
I need everyone to have a beer out okay
oh you want to ask something why did I
write this multiplication here when I've
got a bracket yeah sure there's a good
question I don't have to write that
multiplication sign but I'm writing it
now to remind you all that that's what
I'm doing that
this is shorthand for this that make
sense
and I try to draw the parallel with what
we just did up here all right now just
like before right I could say all right
I've got four of these and four of those
but I just want to make sure you
understand why this is when you say four
times four times itself is an
abbreviation it means this thing written
four times right I know it's gonna be a
bit little various but it's important
just like with index notation that you
see why this is right I'm gonna write it
I love you to write with me a plus seven
we're writing it not once not twice not
three times but four times that's why
it's four times this whoops okay so when
you have a look at this right number one
you're thinking wow that was a lot to
write this is why we're trying to avoid
writing it out in long form like this
but more importantly and if you've got
another color here that might be helpful
more importantly you can see there's a
whole bunch of terms you can put
together right we call this collecting
like terms if you remember this right
how many a terms do you see there four
of them right if you have another color
there I'd love you to highlight thing
with me one two three four every time we
were at a plus seven there was an extra
a right so I'm gonna get for lots of
eight and then when we have a look at
the 7s just like earlier well you've got
four of those as well right so therefore
I can say I'll use a different color
here here my sevens one two three four
so when you add those together that's
what gives you this 28 yeah which we saw
earlier now unlike in our numeric
example because a could be anything I
can't put these together cuz I don't
know what a is at the moment so I
actually just stop there this is it this
is what we call
expanding and expression it's sort of
longer and it's taking up more space
than this where I just have those two
terms ball together okay
now starts to get a bit trickier when
you think about - science when you think
about are the numbers and things are
more complicated for example here's a
third one I'd love you to have a go with
me okay let's do this
ah sorry Christian I can you say that
question again but just a bit louder so
everyone can hear okay so here's the
suggestion right now I hope you can see
where Christians thinking he's got the
28 coming from the 4 and the 7 4 times 7
is 28 right but why aren't we doing
actually 4 times 17 you just came here
they're not well hold on a second
were the white terms here they're
completely unlike that's why I've joined
the different colors right but I did
four times seven like they combined I
did four times a they're not alike they
went together and I got these why can't
I just multiply all the way through
anyway what do you think he because a
person's in packets and actually that's
kind of the see this guy here that's
kind of the key right see how we do we a
plus seven if it was a times seven then
I can multiply all three together and we
we would get this right but in fact I'm
not does that make sense which is why it
was important that we actually show what
it is that we're writing if it was eight
times 7 would be 7 a 7 a 7 a 7 a and
that would be 28 a make sense okay good
sorry I was mid writing of question
let's have this ago I wanted a 4
here we go okay now this one looks a
little bit more confusing there's more
stuff flying around here okay Mary have
a question or a thought okay you're
gonna have to wait my friend okay
because everyone else is not where you
are just yet which is fine
you go ahead and shut down the questions
see if we confirm what you're thinking
in a minute now here there's some extra
stuff firstly there's a number hanging
around the front we'll leave that to one
side for a minute and then you've got
this guy in here and there's an
expansion that I can do that's what
we're interested in right now I could
write this out in long form couldn't I I
could do this I could but I'd really
rather not right
so Cindy what do you think no we could
do okay so I could try going 10 minus 3
and they will give me 7 right that would
be simpler however I want you to think
back to this guy do you remember this
during the duet last year our order of
operations so what should i do before i
get to that merrick or do you think you
yeah so you see here unlike you I didn't
write this multiplication in here but
it's still hiding there
yeah so multiplication actually happens
before we're gonna do that
so trash it is that okay so I'm gonna
take Marik's suggestion negative three
times all that okay hold on a second it
turns out the front I haven't touched it
yet nothing's happened to it there's a
minus 3 times 4 minus 3 times 4 what
does that give you minus 12 just watch
out as you did you said right there's a
minus that hangs around here and that's
kind of really important if I made that
a plus for example I get a whole
different answer wouldn't I yeah okay
now there's a minus 3 it's gonna
multiply by this guy as well right minus
3 times 2 B minus 6 P thank you very
much mr. shocker now can you see what
she just did right just like before and
I'm gonna maybe if you've got some other
colors here you might be able to do this
with me see how I did 4 times a and then
I did 4 times 7 you see that so here I'm
doing exactly the same thing one at a
time he there's a minus 12 where the
miners come from
right there yeah and then the minus is
still there when you have a go at the
next one which is why that minus sign
has come on both of those does that make
sense
if you are like I am not convinced okay
what I'd love you to do is write it out
in longhand you could do I can do it
right now - three of them here's one and
then here's another one and then here's
the third one if you expand out all
these you'll get the same thing it just
takes a lot longer to write okay have a
look am I done
are you happy with that can we can go a
little bit further right say idea what
would you like me to do next yeah these
guys what do we call them again when
they're very similar we call them like
terms so the 10 and the minus 12 we can
collect them together what do I get
negative - okay and what about this
minus 6b what can I do with that there's
not much that's it's it's done it's not
alike so I'm just going to leave it
where it is and be careful to write my B
so it doesn't look like a 6 as well I'm
doing really badly with that I'm doing
B's and essays and terrible choices
sorry guys ok one last one I mean I've
got this so this is example number four
okay
[Music]
okay now these problems are getting
progressively longer but they're not
getting more complicated they're just
getting like the same amount of
complicated and we're just doing it
longer okay now let's just think about
this for a second
I could expand both of these just like I
have before okay
can you help me work out what I would
get if I expanded this first expression
here hmm what do you see Jessica 4m do
you see what you got that for and from
where did she get the 20 from 4 times 5
very good so I could write 4m plus 20
that's the first one about the second
one 2m plus 10 fantastic and then just
like before I've got some got some like
terms yeah I'm gonna highlight them
again with some color so I've got some
M's here and then I've got some
constants right these guys 6m plus 30 so
that's great
are you happy with that answer you're
happy with that you're great okay now
I'm just going to point out one last
thing before we go because I keep
telling you how lazy mathematicians are
right this is correct thumbs up we got
there but there's an even lazier way to
go about this put your pens down for a
minute
maybe you see it okay
I'm gonna ask you in a second here look
before I get to what hearing a
suggestion is you said there was a forum
here at 2m here and you were like oh
those are like terms so I'll put them
together and I get seek him and thumbs
up we got there right
we like flag terms because you can put
them together you can collapse since
much simpler right but did you notice on
the very first line of this question
there are already some like terms did
you spot them here long what are the
like terms do you know they are
that's that's the same term it's just it
long but it's the same time it comes up
twice right you've got four of them here
and then you've got two of them there so
if you got four of some things and two
of some things you'll get six of them
right so I could have done this like so
which gives me the same answer with even
less work okay Vishakha would it be 6m
squared well to answer that question
I'll ask you guys did I get 6m squared
here and the answer is I didn't because
I'm like I've got um if each of my
fingers was an M I've got four of them
here and I've got two here and it would
be really weird if I got fingers squared
that would that would just look funny
right so because I've got four of them
here two of them there I just get six of
them in total
thank goodness for my fingers okay all
right so you can see here when we're
expanding expressions the important
things are number one wherever you can
you collect your like terms together we
don't need to write out in this long way
we can just take one term at a time and
secondly look for things that can make
things a bit easier for you if possible
because the less work there is the less
chance there is for you to make an error
that make sense